Trascrizione: Chiara Carnevali
Revisore: Giulia Virchaux
Frocio, negro, mongoloide.
Queste parole offendono.
Su questo siamo tutti d'accordo.
Vucumprà.
Handicappato, terrone.
Anche queste parole offendono,
però una piccola parte di noi non lo sa
oppure peggio, non lo crede davvero.
Diciamo che fa finta.
Sardegnolo, zitella, sordomuto.
Qui la questione si fa
apparentemente più complicata,
perché queste parole, che sono come sassi,
spesso feriscono solo chi le riceve.
Chi le esprime, in molti casi
è bonariamente inconsapevole
dell’offesa che ha arrecato.
Però queste parole sono veramente pesanti
e, a prescindere dall’intenzione
denigratoria o meno di chi le usa,
esse non sono adatte, non sono adeguate
a descrivere la persona davanti a noi,
ma finché non ce lo dicono
non lo sappiamo.
Per questo motivo, da 16 anni in Italia
esiste una legge, la legge 95 del 2006,
che impone la sostituzione
del termine sordomuto con la parola sordo
in ogni disposizione legislativa vigente.
Ho recitato a memoria l’articoletto,
ora lo sapete anche voi.
Una legge.
C’è voluta una legge?
Purtroppo sì, perché in questo Paese
prevale la retorica demagogica
del “purché si dica con educazione,
si può dire tutto”.
Eh no, tutto proprio no.
Con educazione possiamo dire tutto quello
che so non essere un'offesa per l'altro,
so non essere uno schiaffo per l’altro.
L’altro, molto spesso, non sa neanche
di averla ricevuta, questa offesa.
Ma quando il dubbio proviene
da chi pronuncia quella parola,
dovrebbe almeno rivolgersi alle persone
che quella specifica condizione
la conoscono, la studiano
o, meglio ancora, la vivono.
Provate ad andare da una persona sorda
e chiedetele se sia sordomuta.
Io vi invito veramente a farlo,
perché temo che la risposta
potrebbe essere più o meno piacevole,
ma certamente sarebbe udibile,
persino adesso con una Ffp3.
Altro che muta.
Dunque si dice sordo. Quasi.
Sarebbe ancora meglio “persona sorda”,
perché prima ancora di che cosa abbia
quella persona, essa è una persona.
Poi in questo caso sì, certamente
sarebbe caratterizzata dalla sordità.
Qualcuno di voi potrebbe pensare,
“E invece non udente?”
Beh, un linguaggio inclusivo non punta
al riconoscimento dell’individuo
mettendo in risalto cosa questo non abbia
rispetto a ciò che si ritiene lo standard.
Io non ho bisogno di negare l’altro
per dire chi sono.
Proviamo noi a fare uno sforzo
di autodefinirci per negazione
rispetto allo standard
dal quale ci sentiamo più lontani.
Tra noi potrebbero esserci dei non sexy,
non magri, non smart,
non etero, non resilienti...
Madonna ’sta parola!
Il problema non è quanto siamo
lontani da questo standard.
Il problema è chi decide
che cosa sia uno standard?
E chi decide cosa sia la sordità?
Anni fa ho incontrato l’attivista
e ricercatore inglese sordo Paddy Ladd,
che ha coniato una parola per descrivere
lo status della persona sorda
ed è intraducibile in italiano.
Uno dei famosi prestiti
delle altre lingue.
La parola in questione è “deafhood”.
Non si tratta della già nota “deafness”.
Quella è la sordità vista
da chi sordo non è,
è la mancanza di udito,
è la diagnosi, fondamentalmente.
“Deafhood” è l’identità
della persona sorda, che si sente tale
e pienamente consapevole
di ciò che questo significhi.
In lingua dei segni inglese si segna così
[segna l’orecchio e la pancia]
perché è più un sentire
di pancia che non di testa.
Forse, volendo provare a tradurlo
con uno sforzo pindarico,
dovremmo usare un neologismo,
per esempio “sorditudine”, “sorditanza”
perché in inglese il suffisso -hood
si riserva a tutti gli status emotivi
come “brotherhood”,
“sisterhood”, “childhood”.
Non si dice “sisterness”.
Da questa prospettiva una persona sorda
è molto più di un individuo che non sente.
C’è chi parla persino di “deaf gain”,
il vantaggio di essere sordi.
Ma cosa c’è, nella sordità,
di cui essere tanto orgogliosi?
Per molti questa può sembrare un’eresia,
per altri un pensiero intriso
di quello che Stella Young
ha definito “inspiration porn”,
quella narrazione sensazionalistica
della vita delle persone con disabilità
in cui queste vengono narrate
come eroine, guerriere speciali
capaci di fare di tutto e di più,
anche rappresentare un modello
per chi quella disabilità non la vive.
Ecco un'altra foto.
Eppure, c’è chi nella sordità
trova un habitat, una dimensione
in cui riconoscersi e apprezzarsi.
Queste persone appartengono
a una vera e propria comunità.
Questa parola a volte dà un po fastidio.
Una volta si diceva “comunità sorda”.
Oggi spesso si legge “comunità segnante”.
Io, ad esempio, ne faccio parte,
orgogliosamente aggiungo,
perché appunto annovera
anche persone udenti
che fra le tante cose
che caratterizzano questa comunità,
condividono la conoscenza, lo studio,
l’uso, ma soprattutto il rispetto
della lingua dei segni.
Una comunità che ha una storia
lunghissima, travagliatissima,
ha i propri personaggi di rilievo,
ha i propri problemi interni
come tutte le comunità,
ha la propria cultura, la propria arte.
Una comunità che rivendica
dei diritti negati,
il primo fra tutti l’accesso ai servizi
anche attraverso la lingua dei segni,
cioè la LIS, la lingua dei segni italiana,
e la lotta contro lo stigma
da parte di chi questa comunità
o non la riconosce affatto
o la discrimina.
Esiste un fenomeno analogo
a quello che è l’abilismo,
quando ci si riferisce a una persona sorda
e prende il nome di “audismo”,
ossia assurgere alla condizione di udente
lo status dominante, lo standard appunto,
coerentemente a una società fonocentrica.
E da questa prospettiva obiettivamente
chi è sordo è in condizione di svantaggio,
ha un limite, ha un handicap.
Ecco che si capisce perché compaiano
etichette come “sordo” e “non udente”
rifacendoci a quelle dinamiche
che la psicologia sociale
definisce “ingroup” e “outgroup”,
per cui se io faccio parte di un gruppo
tendo a descrivere in maniera positiva
tutti quelli che fanno parte
del mio gruppo,
e negativa tutti quelli
che non ne fanno parte.
Secondo questa logica,
chi mi ascolta potrebbe pensare:
“Mamma mia che confusione, che casino!”
Da dove nascono
tutte queste possibili interpretazioni
di un fenomeno unico come la sordità?
In parte è un pensiero condivisibile,
in parte questa diversità interpretativa
nasce dalla cosiddetta neurodiversità,
cioè da quello che riguarda tutti noi
come individui, che, in quanto diversi,
abbiamo diverse caratteristiche,
un diverso modo di adattarci all’ambiente.
In parte, però, ha ragioni storiche
che spesso non si conoscono
e questa mi sembrava una buona opportunità
da portare al grande pubblico.
Fino al 1880,
le persone sorde venivano educate
con metodi e strumenti molto eterogenei.
Qualcuno veniva esposto
alla lingua dei segni,
qualcun altro alla lingua vocale,
qualcuno a una combinazione
di lingua dei segni e lingua vocale,
qualcuno alla sola scrittura.
Molti, purtroppo,
non venivano proprio educati.
Dal 6 all′11 settembre 1880,
però, a Milano
si tenne il “Congresso internazionale
pel miglioramento della sorte
dei sordomuti”.
Che titolo!
Tutto un programma.
Peccato che di quella sorte abbiano
discusso prelati, direttori di istituti,
maestri, medici, pedagogisti,
tutta una serie di esperti di sordità,
tranne i maggiori esperti, cioè i sordi.
A onor del vero ce n’erano tre.
Questo è riportato negli atti.
Segnanti, ma senza interprete, fate voi.
Per par condicio va detto che nell’elenco
delle categorie sottorappresentate,
proprio sotto ai sordi, c’erano le donne.
25 su 255 partecipanti totali.
Ad ogni modo il Congresso,
con una serie di autorevolissime fonti
a supporto della tesi dominante,
tra le quali la Bibbia e Manzoni,
sancì che “Il metodo orale
deve essere preferito
a quello della mimica per l’educazione
e l’istruzione de’ sordomuti”
e che “Considerando che l’uso simultaneo
della parola e dei gesti mimici
ha lo svantaggio di nuocere alla parola,
alla lettura sopra le labbra
e alla precisione delle idee,
il metodo orale puro
deve essere preferito”.
La sintesi di queste infondate conclusioni
è passata alla storia con questo slogan:
“Il gesto uccide la parola”.
Purtroppo questa frase è ancora in essere,
ancora in uso presso persone disinformate.
Non è infrequente sentire molte persone,
se non addirittura dei clinici,
che dicono alle famiglie che ricevono
la diagnosi di sordità del proprio figlio:
“Mi raccomando, per favore, non esponetelo
alla lingua dei segni, sennò non parlerà”.
Ecco, ogni volta che sento questa frase,
è come se sentissi lo stesso clinico
che dice a quella famiglia:
“Mi raccomando, non esponete vostro figlio
al gioco con le pentoline e con le bambole
altrimenti poi diventa gay”.
Sento la stessa cosa.
A onor del vero vi racconto questa cosa,
sebbene sia surreale,
ma ci tengo a condividerla.
Una volta un genitore ha esternato
questo pensiero sulle pentoline con me.
Che, se non fosse chiaro... con me.
Quindi ho pensato di tenerlo
in stanza per cinque mesi
perché il bambino aveva un disturbo
di linguaggio importante
e di usare un gioco che lui amava,
la cucina, per stimolare il linguaggio
far emergere queste parole
che facevano fatica.
E dopo cinque mesi di lavoro estenuante,
dopo tutta la vita che c’è stata dopo,
oggi questo bambino ha vent’anni,
è un affermatissimo cuoco,
lavora dentro un ristorante
in cui è nel suo habitat,
si sente riconosciuto.
E io credo che quel genitore,
e questo vorrei dirlo a tutti i genitori,
l’unica cosa che si può temere
quando un bambino gioca con le pentoline
è che quando lui avrà la capacità
di passare dalla finzione alla realtà,
tu non avrai più il fisico per assaggiare
quello che lui ti porta già cucinato.
Adesso vorrei lasciarvi delle riflessioni
tornando alla sordità.
La prima è che dopo il 1880 la comunità
scientifica ha fatto passi da gigante,
ha fatto un’autocritica e oggi sappiamo
che quanto detto in passato era un errore.
Non solo non è vero che un bambino sordo
esposto alla lingua dei segni non parlerà,
ma questa particolare forma di bilinguismo
italiano e lingua dei segni,
chiamata bilinguismo bimodale,
apre delle opportunità uniche al mondo.
Uno dei ragazzi che ho seguito e che seguo
ha un impianto cocleare,
non è mai stato esposto
alla lingua dei segni,
non aveva mai conosciuto
un’altra persona sorda.
E siamo a Cagliari, non a Manhattan.
È estremamente timido, ma è anche
una persona con una particolare attitudine
nel saper trasformare in disegni
i propri pensieri.
Durante il percorso di logopedia
fatto con un altro ragazzo sordo segnante
che è emigrato in Italia quattro anni fa
e che è invece estremamente comunicativo,
ha prodotto un album illustrato
in cui racconta i suoi pensieri.
Uno dei disegni che ha prodotto è questo.
No, il precedente.
(Ridacchia)
Prima, prima, prima.
Ancora, questo qui.
Lui dice, “Mi sono sentito travolto
da questo mare di conversazioni
fatte di segni e parole.
Ho imparato molte cose
sulla lingua dei segni
e ho l’impressione
che tutte queste informazioni
nella mia testa non ci stiano.
È come se si fosse aperta una porta
sul mondo della lingua dei segni,
in cui mani e braccia
si muovono senza sosta
e dove le pause della lingua che conoscevo
fino ad allora non ci sono più,
perché adesso io posso parlare e segnare
senza smettere mai di comunicare.
Quando ero piccolo mi è stato impedito
di imparare la lingua dei segni
perché, mi avevano assicurato,
dovevo concentrarmi sulla lingua vocale.
Invece oggi io la rimpiango
perché attraverso i segni ho imparato
a esplorare i miei pensieri e a tradurli
in immagini che posso condividere
e comunicare con tutti”.
Spesso sento dire,
“Ma che senso ha la lingua dei segni
nell’era degli impianti cocleari?
Abbiamo gli apparecchi acustici,
il progresso tecnologico”
e, di nuovo, per quello strano meccanismo
per il quale sento parlare di pentoline,
nella testa ascolto un’analogia metaforica
ed è come se sentissi la frase
“Ma che senso ha al giorno d’oggi
una giacca d’abito quando abbiamo i jeans
e le t shirt?”.
E io dico, ma perché devo scegliere
se li posso mettere tutti e due,
se li posso usare tutti e due?
Perché presentare la lingua dei segni
e la tecnologia per l’ascolto assistito
come in competizione quando in realtà
assolvono la stessa funzione,
cioè favorire la comunicazione
e il linguaggio per le persone sorde
e possono farlo in modo cooperante
anziché conflittuale.
Dall’unione di questi due elementi,
come accade per la giacca
e i jeans con la t-shirt,
che sono già utili allo scopo da soli,
ma ancora più utili in combinazione,
quindi in questo caso
lingua vocale e lingua dei segni,
una qualunque persona,
non soltanto una persona sorda,
potrebbe parlare e segnare a volte,
solo segnare in altri momenti,
solo parlare in altri ancora.
Potrei raccontarvi un’infinità di cose,
ma mi ricordo in maniera molto chiara
la prima volta che ho presentato
i miei amici sordi ai miei amici udenti
quando sono venuto a vivere a Cagliari.
Era una città nuova, che stava al mare.
C'era una festa.
Tutti quanti i miei amici sordi avevano
apparecchi acustici o impianti cocleari
e a un certo punto
si chiacchierava tutti insieme,
a qualcuno non era neanche chiaro
che i miei amici fossero sordi,
ma quando la musica
si è alzata all’improvviso,
al Poetto la conversazione
è diventata insostenibile,
era veramente faticoso parlare.
Quindi tutti intorno a noi
hanno cominciato a parlare.
Avete presente le mamme quando passano
l’aspirapolvere, entrano in camera tua
e comunque hanno la pretesa di conversare?
(Urla)
Questa roba qui. Tutti facevano così,
tranne me e i miei amici sordi
che invece abbiamo smesso di parlare
e abbiamo proseguito la conversazione
comodamente in lingua dei segni.
E quando uno di noi è andato
a fare la fila per i drink,
è stato sufficiente segnare
da lontano “quattro gin tonic”.
L’ordine è stato presto fatto
senza sgolarci.
Io potrei elencarvi un’infinità
di applicazioni pratiche
della lingua dei segni
alle situazioni di tutti i giorni.
Copiare agli esami scritti
senza che il professore se ne accorga,
senza fare cose tipo: “(sottovoce) 14, H”.
(Segna) Bah, 14, H, fatto!
Spettegolare di qualcuno
senza che questo se ne accorga,
quando è presente, ce l’hai lì davanti,
è li con te, non è che devi indicare,
è proprio seduto davanti a te,
ma parli malissimo di lui.
Comunicare in maniera ininterrotta
a tavola pure quando hai il cibo in bocca.
E voi direte, ma perché?
Perché c’è gente logorroica come me,
o non avrei fatto questo lavoro,
che ha voglia di parlare
pure con la roba in bocca,
come Fantozzi con le polpette, no?
E poi ricorrere ancora ai segni
quando le parole da sole non bastano più,
oppure si potrebbe dire quella cosa
in maniera ancora più intensa,
come per dire, per esempio, “mi dispiace”,
o per dire “ti amo”
letteralmente “darti il mio cuore”.
Perché la verità è che ognuno di noi
ha il diritto di esprimersi come vuole
e non è giusto che sia qualcun altro
a dirci come farlo o convincerci
che un modo sia migliore di un altro.
Oltretutto questo battibeccarsi,
spesso sui social,
tra lingua dei segni e lingua vocale,
fa male a tutte quelle famiglie
e tutte quelle persone che hanno trovato
nella comunicazione multimodale
o in lingua dei segni una soluzione
per far sì che la sordità o le disabilità
che a volte sono associate alla sordità
non siano tali, e non siano un handicap.
Perché non tutti siamo uguali.
Ognuno di noi ha una storia
e andrebbe rispettata, conosciuta
a partire da cosa scelgo di postare
e cosa scelgo di comunicare.
Ci sono molte cose che vorrei dirvi
del mio lavoro, ma io sono un logopedista
e sono molto felice
del lavoro che ho scelto.
Perché sebbene nell’immaginario collettivo
noi siamo quelli delle paroline,
quelli che ti aiutano a parlare,
in realtà noi stiamo zitti per molto tempo
al giorno, soprattutto in seduta.
E la cosa bella è che non chiediamo nulla
alla persona che ci chiede aiuto
di diverso da quello
che sceglie di portare.
Spesso la persona stessa sceglie
di stare zitta in nostra presenza,
perché la logopedia è uno spazio
in cui la persona che ha bisogno di aiuto
porta quello che si sente di portare.
Il logopedista aggiunge degli ingredienti
che hanno a che fare col sapere,
col saper fare, ma soprattutto
col saper essere.
Si mescolano un po’ questi ingredienti,
si dà forma a un qualcosa
dove si spera che la persona
che ci aveva chiesto aiuto si identifichi,
trovi una propria identità,
un proprio funzionamento,
ma soprattutto che l’accetti
e vi si riconosca.
Io ripeto spesso una frase
a tutti i bambini sordi
con i quali ho la fortuna di lavorare.
Io dico loro: “Tu non sei il tuo impianto
cocleare o il tuo apparecchio acustico.
Tu sei questa”, e tocco loro la testa.
“Trattala bene”.
Lo faccio perché spesso
assisto a una tale magificazione
dell’impianto cocleare
o dell’apparecchio acustico
che i bambini e le persone sorde tendono
a venerare questo oggettivo miracolo
della tecnologia,
dimenticando, perdendo completamente
di vista chi loro siano, la loro identità.
Una volta mi ricordo, a un adolescente
ho chiesto: “Tu hai un talento?”
E lui mi ha risposto:
“Sì, ho l’impianto cocleare”.
Rimasi spiazzato.
Spesso chi non mi conosce
o non conosce il mio lavoro
crede che io sia un avversario
della tecnologia
o dell’abilitazione alla lingua vocale
e invece sono un profondo e serio studioso
di tutte e due le cose
però lo sono anche della lingua dei segni.
Lo sono della logogenia,
un importantissimo strumento
per fornire una stimolazione grammaticale
alle persone sorde e non solo.
Lo sono anche della comunicazione
alternativa aumentativa
e di tutte le cose che possono servire
a una persona sorda
per trovare il proprio posto nel mondo
e la propria identità.
Quante volte ho sentito dire:
“Tizio è sordomuto ma parla benissimo,
guarda nemmeno te ne accorgi,
è veramente in gamba”,
o peggio, dei genitori che al momento
della scelta del processore esterno
dell’impianto cocleare,
non so se ne abbiate mai visto uno,
dicono: “Guarda, questo marrone, grazie,
nemmeno si noterà sotto i capelli
di nostra figlia”.
Io sogno una società in cui nessuno
penserebbe di lodare una persona sorda
unicamente per quanto il suo linguaggio
sia simile a quello di una persona udente.
Così come sogno dei genitori
che al momento della scelta
di questo famoso processore esterno
opteranno per quello giallo fluo,
quello arcobaleno, quello con le cose
più visibili del mondo.
Perché la verità è che se una cosa
non me la mostri, io non la conoscerò mai.
Alla stregua di quello che vi ho detto,
vorrei però dare delle informazioni utili
a chi tutte queste cose
vorrebbe masticarle con più calma.
Nel 2020, insieme ad altri
41 professionisti, ho partecipato
a un evento gratuito, super partes
che insieme ad altri professionisti,
psicologi, audiologi, audiometristi
ha fornito dei confronti “all’americana”,
passatemi il termine.
In cui un moderatore e due esperti
si confrontano su vari temi
legati alla sordità,
sono accessibili, sono ancora su internet,
sono gratuiti, quindi andate a visitarli.
Il nome dell’evento è “Sordità infantile,
una discussione partecipata”
organizzata dal CIMeC dell’Università
di Trento e dal CNR di Roma.
Il mio tempo è decisamente quasi finito
quindi vorrei lasciarvi delle riflessioni
verso la fine.
Il punto è che le persone sorde
sono tante, sono diversissime.
Non esiste una persona sorda
uguale a un’altra persona sorda.
Alcune di queste hanno scelto
la LIS come lingua madre
e si sentono parte di questa comunità.
Molte altre non hanno mai nemmeno visto
un’altra persona sorda.
Sono perfettamente integrate nella società
di maggioranza, diciamo la società udente
e quando si chiede loro se siano sorde
storcono un po’ il naso.
Non sono neanche troppo a loro agio
con questa definizione,
ma moltissime altre sono andate ben oltre
questa definizione dicotomica.
Non gliene frega niente di definirsi
in base al codice che usano per esprimersi
e queste persone sono sinceramente curiose
verso qualunque opportunità per conoscersi
e per conoscere l’altro.
Il ragazzo sordo che ha fatto il disegno
che vi ho mostrato prima è presente
in sala questa sera.
Vi voglio mostrare un ultimo disegno.
Non è tutto, è un dettaglio.
Ha partecipato al percorso di logopedia
insieme al suo compagno migrante.
Ultimamente, pochi giorni fa,
ha prodotto questo disegno.
Lui quando ha questi slanci emotivi
produce dei disegni.
Lo ha fatto per lui e la spiegazione
di questo disegno ve la leggo.
“Le mani sono quelle di Valerio,
il nostro logopedista,
che sostengono il mio compagno di viaggio
nel suo percorso di crescita e di scoperta
della propria identità di persona sorda.
I fiori sono i frutti della mia vicinanza
a lui, che in realtà sbocciano
in chiunque voglia conoscerlo.
La LIS, l’amore, l’amicizia, l’allegria”.
Grazie.
(Applausi)